smartest people I've ever met in my life
know exactly how and when to play stupid
yeah it's interesting there's not a lot
of advantage to having the other person
think you're smart there's many
advantages to having them think you're
stupid there are some times where it is
advantageous to be perceived as a bigger
threat and it's actually when you're
weaker it's always in the reverse
situation so if you are strong you want
to appear weak and when you are weak you
want to appear strong so that you have
fewer threats and so it's always trying
to play the opposite position of where
you're at which is why deception is a
big part of War